[Music]
they have been the focus of fascination
in movies for decades
[Music]
black holes have been imagined by
hollywood plenty of times
but this week scientists across seven
countries released the first ever image
of the black hole at the center of the
milky way
today the event horizon telescope is
delighted to share with you the first
direct image
of the gentle giant in the center of our
galaxy sagittarius a star
sagittarius a is four million times as
massive as the sun
a region so dense not even light can
escape its gravitational pull
this week's image follows the release of
what it sounds like inside a black hole
which we heard for the first time
earlier this month
[Music]
the picture is courtesy of the event
horizon a series of 11 telescopes set up
around the world from hawaii to
greenland
black holes are of course black so what
you're seeing are actually the boundary
shadows of the black hole bumping up
against gas and dust outside
the edge of a galaxy we can see
and what we can't
i have always been fascinated by black
holes the idea of what's on the other
side
the big question
yeah if you go we'll never see you again
i mean it scares a lot of people which
is why they went out of their way at
this news conference to call it a gentle
giant gentle giant that sucks everybody
that was just nice that eats everything
but yeah that's not true but well maybe
it is
but anyway i mean just a fascinating way
that they with these 11 different
telescopes heard the radio waves picked
them up
and then created this image yeah
very cool she was